techno Marxarxism. That's the world
we're going into. They want a numb and
indifferent population that they can
enslave, that they can rule over, who
are complacent. What they want is
compliancy. I feel sorry for these
people because the way the world is
going, I don't think that they are
psychologically equipped to survive.
The entire universe is watching what we
do. We are all connected to the entire
universe. And each of us can be a
beautiful ray of light if we will it, if
we choose it to be. What power is is the
capacity to direct and focus our
attention. And before for the longest
time, the best and easiest way to focus
our attention was money, right? So
wealth isn't money. What wealth is is
our attention, our consciousness.
towards you matter, but you have to
choose to matter. You have to believe
that you matter. And honestly, I think
it's a message that the elite have
purposefully hid from us.
Hi friends, it's a pleasure to tell you
that my book What It Takes Southeast
Asia has been released in English and
Bahasa Indonesia. You can buy it through
books.game.id
or at any of these stores. Now back to
the show. Hi friends. So today we're
honored to uh be graced by Jang Suin who
has uh given lots of analyses about
what's happening around the world. Jang,
thank you so much for gracing our show.
>> Thanks so much for inviting me.
>> Yeah, I want to start out with how you
grew up. Uh you grew up in Canada and
you've uh you've you know mentioned that
you know you you were not at the top of
the class but you were up there within
the top echelon. Uh and then you decided
to go to Yale and and tell us what
shaped your early educational journey,
>> right? So um I grew up as an immigrant
in Toronto, Canada and my parents were
very poor and they were not well
educated. So we would have qualified for
um welfare. You know, Canada has a very
nice social service uh system and
welfare is actually very very nice. But
my parents didn't speak English. They
didn't know the system. So, we actually
lived worse than people on welfare,
meaning that we didn't go out at all.
Um, we didn't really have meat at the
table. We had vegetables. We never
vacation. Um, I we only got a car when I
was like 16. So, so we moved over when I
was 6 years old. So, um, we took public
transport uh everywhere. And the
highlight in our life was like a monthly
dim sum lunch. Um, so it was a pretty
hard upbringing. I studied in uh
throughout school because I am a very
sensitive uh very active person with a
lot of curiosity and the stress and the
trauma of growing up as an immigrant
uh in Toronto uh really affected my
speech patterns and the kids made fun of
me because my dad cut my hair, my mom
bought clothing at, you know, bargain
outlets. Um, and we got I I I I wore a
lot of clothes that were too oversized
because they were hand-me-downs from
cousins
and uh it was a very hard upbringing. My
dad was a dishwasher and he was working
in a restaurant and as you can imagine
being an immigrant uh Chinese immigrant
who didn't speak very much English um he
was um he he suffered a lot under a lot
of racism and that transferred in the
household and my dad was a very violent
and angry man. He was actually a high
school teacher in China and he had a lot
of status, a lot of prestige and he
enjoyed his job. But you know this was
during the cultural revolution and when
it ended in 1976 he looked for the
opportunity to go abroad to build a
better future for um his children. Um
and so I grew up in a very tense very
traumatic environment um that let left
basically left me depressed and angry
for most of my life. and I wanted to
escape my environment and so um I
applied to university and I wanted to
get out of Canada and apparently the Ivy
League took young promising students and
so I was not at that point I was like 16
years old when I decided to apply to
Yale I was not a promising student um I
watched cartoons um I didn't really read
that many books but um I was intent on
getting out of And uh so I repackaged
myself. I manufactured myself as a as a
plausible candidate uh for for Yale and
um I joined the soccer team because it
was the easiest athletic team to join.
Uh I was not an athletic person but they
were desperate for recruits. Um I uh I I
started to read a lot of books. I
crammed for the SATs. I took the hardest
courses and out of pure pure luck. Okay.
I mean it it was just pure luck. But I
applied to uh four universities.
Harvard, Yale, Princeton, MIT. Harvard
was the first to reject me. But they
wrote a very nice consolation letter. By
the way, guys, if you apply to Harvard
and they reject you, it's a very nice
feeling because they tell you it's not
where you go, it's what you do when you
get there. And it's something that I
remember for the rest of my life. So, um
I thank Harvard for for such a nice
letter. So, Harvard was the first to
reject me, then Princeton and MIT. And I
and I thought there was no chance I
would get into Yale. And I think that um
when I applied it 1995 so the year was
1995 and by early April basically all
the uh decision letters would come uh in
and by like you know midappril I still
have not heard from Yale. So I sort of
like forgot about this and um I came to
the resolution that you know what
mattered was not the destination. What
matters is a journey. The fact of the
matter is that I proved that I could
radically transform myself if I set
myself a higher goal. And so I was
thankful for the journey and I just
accept the fact that I would go to
Wateroo uh which is which is engineering
university in Canada. It's actually
pretty good. So I was not
>> Yeah. So I was not unhappy about it. But
then um at the end of April, I received
a letter from Yale. Now the thing to
know about the US application process is
that you know from the size of the
envelope if they accepted you or
rejected you right so if they accepted
you it's a huge envelope because they
want too right yeah
>> it's very thick it's because they have a
lot of brochures they want to sell you
on um on on on wanting the the
acceptance right they want you to accept
their acceptance right so usually you
just know from the size of the envelope
if you got in or not so I got a small
envelope. Okay. And that basically means
rejection and you know I I mean um it it
it I I I had already decided that I was
not get going to get into Yale and um I
sort of dis dismissed it and I actually
wanted to form the garbage because like
like why do I why do I want to read
another rejection letter? Okay. So um I
was pretty despondent and I wanted to
form the garbage but I said no I have to
read the rejection letter because it
might say something nice. So, I went up
to my room. I put my backpack on on the
bed. I laid I laid down on the on my bed
and it was pretty dark. I I remember it
being a very dark room. And I opened the
letter and the first word I said the
first word that it said was
congratulations.
And that was a shock. I mean, like like
it was it was someone punched me. And
and I I didn't know what I was what I
was reading. So, I I kept on reading and
it seemed as though Yo had accepted me,
but I didn't believe it. So what I did
was the first thing I did was I picked
up the phone and I called Yale
University. It took me half an hour, but
I finally got food and admissions
officer who confirmed that I' had been
accepted into Yale. And um and that's
the story. And and and you know that
forever changed my life because going to
Yale, as you can imagine, opened up the
entire world to uh to me.
>> Wow.
Talk about the essay that you wrote. Uh
when I was a high school student, um I
went to a normal high school in Toronto,
my world was was very limited and I
didn't have packagers, you know, they're
called packagers who help you write the
essays. Uh I didn't have people I knew
who went to Yale and who could guide me
uh in the process. So I just wrote a
very mundane essay. I mean I wrote about
my love for Richard Fineman, you know.
Um at that time in high school, I fell
in love with physics. I fell in love
with quantum physics. I watched all
Richard Feman's lectures. I I just think
he's the he's the greatest science
educator ever. Um yeah and um so I wrote
about um my love for Richard Feman and
how I myself wanted to pursue particle
physics and then I I did that for a year
at Yale and I gave up because I was not
cut out to be a particle physicist. I
switch over to to the other extreme
which was English poetry. Right. So I
went from particle physics to English
poetry. Um, after one year,
>> did you know anything about English lit
or English poetry or you just it was
random?
>> Yeah, I know. I mean, I um I mean it was
a it was a standard Toronto public
school education. So, in high school,
you know, you um you read Hamlet, you
read Julius Caesar, um but you also read
a lot of like bad Canadian fiction, they
make you read bad Canadian fiction. Uh
they make you read Azro, Margaret
Atwood, and I mean they're good writers.
I mean like but when you're a high
school student um who's a Chinese
immigrant as Monroe and Margaret Atward
are not talking to you, you know, you're
not connecting with these um uh with
with with their uh protagonist and I
didn't really care about menopause. I
really didn't care about these things,
you know, and so that turned me off. But
when I went to Yale, um the great thing
about Yale is it's a liberal arts
school, right? So they encourage you to
take a wide spectrum of classes. Um
there are four groupings. There's the
languages, um there's the uh humanities,
there's the social sciences, and there's
the sciences. And you're supposed to
take certain courses in all four
different groupings. So I stuck taking
English uh literature, and I fell in
love. I mean, uh the first semester, we
read books I've never heard of. So, we
read Spencer, uh, The Fairy Queen. We
read Chaucer, the Canterbury Tales, uh,
Andrew Marvel, and I've never heard of
these people in my life, but, um, there
was something about the poetry. It was
it was as though that in the page there
was almost like a divine spark. It was
almost as as though the words were alive
in in poetry. And that sort of compelled
me or that sort of uh attracted me,
seduced me to want to know more. In the
second semester, we started to read
Paradise Lost. And I love Paradise Lost.
I mean, like that was the that that was
the moment that clicked like, "Wow, John
Milton is a genius. This poetry is the
work of God." I mean, John Milton was
this prophet and God uh was uh was
through him speaking the truth to the
world and and that's when I fell in love
with uh poetry. So, John Milton was a
major breakthrough. John Keats was a big
major breakthrough when brother Yates
was a breakthrough TS Elliott and and
and and that's when um I realized that I
want to do this for the rest of my life.
Um maybe not research English literature
because as as you can imagine you
probably know this but acade academia
can be very dry. Uh you know you're very
focused on very uh narrow topics and I
was a very wide ranging thinker. Um I I
was very curious. I thought I felt that
you know to to try to understand the
world through a literary lens to try to
read people as though they were a book
um trying to decipher a sort of person
by analyzing a person's language. uh
that was very very appealing to me and
that and I I received a very strong
training in that and something that I I
carried with me for the rest of my life
because after Yale I was a journalist
and so um as a journalist you have to
have empathy you have to try to see
things from other people's perspective
so that literature background was very
important for that I was a teacher I'm
still a teacher um and as you can
imagine um literature equips you with a
very strong communication um very strong
uh communication and so So that
education um really empowered me for for
for the rest of my life.
>> Did did you ever have any curiosity with
respect to the Russian stuff or the
Chinese stuff toki?
>> Right. So
>> yeah.
>> Right. So again you receive a very broad
education at Yale. So it's fascinated
with Russian culture and history uh and
literature. Um so I did read Pisto. I
love Anacarina. Um I I I read that at
Yale. It it's it's such a wonderful
wonderful book. Um I spent a lot of time
focusing on the Russian Revolution. Um
so we read Vlad Vladimir Lenin. Uh we we
we were reading Marx. Uh we were trying
to understand the uh Russian Revolution.
Um I took a course on
>> uh Russian history which I which I
believe was taught by Peter Steinberg
and and he he's a very prominent Russian
historian. Um and it was it was a
wonderful course. Um, and yeah, so I I I
I do have some background in in that.
Yes.
>> Because I would have thought that, you
know, you you've you've talked quite a
bit about how class structures are
shaped by ideology and, you know, how
Marxism, socialism, communism,
capitalism. I mean a lot of the stuff
would have you know been shaped by a lot
of the readings that came out of Russia
and other European countries and of
course you know the UK and the US now
did you come across the the secret
society at Yale the bones and skulls
right so um and I mean like everyone
knows this but even at Yale there's a
hierarchy and skull and bones is at the
very top so I didn't know this at that
time when I first went to Yale. Um, but
you know, if you come from the private
school boarding system, and a lot of
Yaleies did come from that system like
Graten and Endover and Exiter and St.
Paul's, they they knew the point of
going to Yale was to try to get into one
of these secret societies your senior
year. You know, it's the same system at
Princeton and Harvard where uh, you
know, it's a hierarchy and the the very
point um of a university is to prove
your social worth. Um, but I didn't know
that. I mean, like I was just this poor
Chinese immigrant who luck myself who
looked into Yale uh from Toronto. So, I
was very naive
um about Yale. And I thought, well, the
entire point of going to Yale is to get
an education, right? The entire point of
Yale is to read good books, talk to your
professors, and open your mind. And so,
that's what I did for four years. But I
wasn't really involved in the the social
scene. I wasn't really involved in like
the politics where you know you meet
friends, you join the right clubs but
but but this this this is what I know
about Skone and Bones. Okay, so Skone
Bones um every year 12 juniors are
tapped. Okay, they're um 12 or 15.
>> Excuse me.
>> I thought it was 15. Oh, it's 12 now.
Okay.
>> You know, you know what? You know what?
I thought it was 12, but it could be 15.
Okay. So So maybe 15 could be 12. I'm
not sure. Okay. But you don't apply. You
don't you you don't you you're tapped.
Okay. Me meaning that you're told to go
to a certain place. Um so you're tapped.
Uh that's the first thing I know. Second
thing that I know is that those 15 who
are selected come from very diverse
background. So just look at who gets in.
It's always one person who has a
fanatical religious background. It's
another person who's a whose dad is a
famous alumni. Another person is going
to go into politics. Another person is
editor of the Yale Daily News. Another
person is head of the student
government. Uh so so so the 15 is meant
to be diverse and it's sort of
pre-ordained. Uh and and people spend a
lot of time, you know, jockeying to be
editor of the Yale uh daily news. Okay.
So that's something um I know. So I'll
I'll tell you something funny. So I'm
the class of 1999. And apparently the
class of 1999 was a mediocre class and
that's probably how I got in. Um um and
so that year I knew who I I my friend
was the editor of the Yale Daily News
and he was so angry that he was not
tapped to join Skill and Bones that he
started his own secret society and you
know he he was rich. So, but like like
like that's that just knows just the
absurdity of the competition, you know,
around joining these secret societies
and and and and so yeah, so he and some
other people start their own secret
society. He he thought that, you know, I
I'm not ed of Daily News and so I must
be tapped, but but apparently it's not
that um I mean it's not that strict. Um,
and um, uh, the third thing I will say
about Scrum and Bones is that the people
that I know who got into Scrum Bones are
actually pretty low-key people. They're
not people you you would think are
intellectually vibrant and charismatic.
Um, these are people who are pretty
low-key and and I think a lot of it is
like they know how the system works and
they're sort of born in that in that
position and they know how how to
navigate that system. So um so yeah so
so so I yeah I do know about Skull and
Bones but to be honest with you um I was
in a different world. I was very much
marginalized and alienated at at Yale.
>> Did did you get a sense at that time
that that was sort of like a the way for
anybody to
get powerful, get rich or whatever. that
that was a precondition for somebody to
belong to some ritual, you know,
activity in order to be powerful or to
be wealthy, to be rich or to be whatever
in a position of leadership or
authority,
>> right? So again, I was very naive when I
was at Yale. Um, you know, I was a poor
person. I have absolutely no idea how
power works. So I believe in the
complete opposite where the world is run
by ideas. So if you're able to produce
prod produce the best ideas somehow
naturally I don't know how but somehow
naturally you flow into positions of
power and so the world is run by a
hierarchy of ideas and the people at the
very top are those who have the best
ideas and people at the bottom have the
worst ideas and so it's a meritocracy
and like being at Yale and you know Yale
prided itself on the surface ostensibly
as being like that it's not really like
that but like you know I didn't know
anything I was naive and I was very
thankful that I got a full scholarship
to study at Yale. So I believe like this
is how Yale works and this is how the
entire world works. And as you can
imagine, I was in for a shock and
surprise when I actually went out into
the world and recognized that that's not
how the world works, man. It's all
Guansi. It's all who you know. And so
for about 10 plus years, I became very
depressed. I became very angry because,
you know, I put myself in the classroom
at Yale. Um, I didn't get get into skull
bones. I didn't get become a role
scholar. But in the classroom, you know,
where where, you know, it's almost a
glad gladoral combat of ideas. I mean,
like I was a very proficient warrior. I
mean, I I had some very interesting
things to say in class. And so my
professors um I I was you know they
thought very highly of me and they was
was they they were they were actually
pretty confident that I would be
successful in life. And so I go out into
the world and I and then you know it's
one failure after another failure. I
failed as a journalist. I failed as a
teacher. I couldn't really find
employment. I became extremely
frustrated. I became very angry. And
that uh forced me into a deep
depression, which by the way today I'm
very thankful for because it really um
it really shocked me, traumatized me
into reimagining how the world works.
And I don't think that without that sort
of like four or five years of outright
depression of just sitting at home and
feeling sorry for myself and hating the
world, it was not possible for me to res
resurrect myself and have a more nuanced
and subtle understanding of the world.
And I know this because I have a lot of
friends who went to Yale, Harvard, and
Princeton and they're very successful
people. Uh very wealthy and like when we
start talk about like world events about
Donald Trump, about Vladimir Putin,
about this war in Russia, about the
worst war in Iran, they don't get it,
man. But, you know, they're still stuck
in this CNN, New York Times mindset in
that, you know, Trump is just deranged
and after he leaves office in um, you
know, 3 years. I mean, like, he's still
he still be around for a long time,
right? But once he leaves office, things
will go back to 2020. Things will go
back to normal. And also, it's possible
that the Democrats win the midterms in
November and then he'll be impeached and
then we'll go back to normal. this war
in Iraq will work and we'll go back to
normal. Don't worry, we'll go back to
normal. So, they have their heads in the
sand. And you know what? I'll be honest
with you. I feel sorry for these people
because the world the world as it is,
the way the world is going, I don't
think that they are psychologically
equipped to survive.
It's pretty scary, man. I want to want
to pick up on journalism and and I'll
come back to the US and Trump and all
that. How how do you see journalism in
terms of its evolution from 1995
to today? I mean, you know, we we were
shackled by mainstream, right, in ' 80s,
'90s, probably to the extent of early
2000s, but now people are I I I I don't
think they're looking at mainstream the
way people would have been looking at
mainstream in the '9s and ' 80s. How how
do you think journalism has evolved
until recently or today? And how do you
think it's going to evolve going forward
for the benefit of humanity?
>> Right. So, so let let me start with a
story. So the year is 1999 and I had
just graduated from Yale and I went to
Beijing to learn the language to sort of
acclimatize myself into Chinese culture
because you know I'm Chinese but grow up
in Toronto going to Yale I didn't really
know that. So I wanted to like
rediscover my roots um and really try to
understand myself. Plus I was very
lonely and I wanted to meet friends. So,
so I I go to Beijing and pure
coincidence, but a very famous American
writer named Gay Tiss um he was actually
in Beijing for the first time in his
life researching a story and
he couldn't speak Chinese and so through
a mutual friend I was introduced to Gay
Tis and and be and I was his translator
for six months and that was really the
best education you could have as a
journalist as a want to be journalist
and He really inspired me to want to be
a journalist. And you know like Gay Tiss
is old school journalist. I mean he
really it ep epitomizes the golden age
of journalism when you know journalists
were part of history and they were
making history. Um you know his book uh
thy neighbor's wife really changed the
American sexual discourse in the 1980s
and uh you know he knew everyone. I mean
he was friends with Donald Trump. He was
friends with everyone in America um at
that time. And you know just being with
him first of all it it made me idealize
journalism and think that journalism is
really about truth seeeking because that
that's what he told me every single day
we we we had dinner together you know
like like journalists are making
history. They are the ones recording
history and they are recording history
from a critical lens because most
journalists I mean when he was a
journalist most journalists were working
class. I mean he was not a Yale
graduate. Uh he was not a wasp was not a
blueb blood. He was a child of Italian
immigrants who grew up in Ocean City,
New Jersey and he saw a lot of he
suffered under a lot of racism
discrimination when he grew up and that
made him a stranger in America. that
enabled him to see America through a
more nuance, more critical lens. And if
you actually read his stories uh from
the early days of his New York Times
career, his stories on Flat Floyd
Patterson, uh you know, you recognize
that he has a real appreciation for the
underdog, for the oppressed, right?
>> You know, he he talks about how he never
wanted to interview the winners of a
sports match. He always wanted to
interview the losers of a sport sports
match because that was a much more
compelling human narrative. So he had a
profound impact in the way that I saw
myself as a journalist as well as
journalism in general. And so I saw it I
saw journalism as really about fighting
for the truth about fighting for the
common man. And that's and that's an
attitude I maintained for the longest
time until
2016. Okay. But 2016 was when Donald
Trump won. And then after 2016,
journalism broke, right? I mean, like
before, journalism prided itself on
being at least fair and balanced. But in
2016 when Donald Trump won like
journalism just developed TDS, Trump
derangement syndrome and then
journalists started to align themselves
with the national security apparatus,
right? people like John Brennan and like
these people were these spies were
featured prominently in the media and
they were they were u promoting uh
hoaxes such as wash Russia gate, right?
Oh, Trump is actually a Putin spy and
Trump won election because the Russians
rigged it in his favor and like like I I
just saw the like the gradual decline of
journalism and then you know after that
was the co affair and I was in China at
that time and I didn't think it was that
that big of a deal but the journalist
journalism was making out to be like
this you know uh apocalypse then of
course was the war in uh Ukraine And I
mean that was just pure dingoism, right?
I mean like rather than trying to report
the the war in a fair and balanced
manner, it was just like you know Russia
is this uh evil empire that's about
that's about to collapse at any point.
Ukraine is heroic and it it didn't it
didn't go into any of the history behind
this war and the fact that you know the
ass battalion are a bunch of neo-Nazis.
They never ever mentioned that. It's
something that you have to learn from um
online media, independent media. So
think uh so I learned that from the
Jimmy door show. Okay. So at that point,
okay, by the time the war in Ukraine, I
had given up on journalism. Now I
switched to the internet. I was watching
Jimmy Door a lot. I was watching Ter
Carson a lot. I was a huge fan of Ter
Carson at that point because he was the
only one who was actually speaking the
truth about the world.
>> Oh yeah.
>> Um so so so yeah. And
>> try to stop the war.
>> Yeah. Exactly.
>> Try to stop the war three times. Yeah,
I'm actually talk talking to Taro
Carlson next week. We have a two-hour uh
conversation schedule. So, I'm really
I'm about that because, you know, like
as you said, as you said, he's been
working his ass off for the past 10
years trying to stop America from
imploding from from like committing
suicide. You know, he was the one who
tried to stop the Ukraine war, but he he
but you know, he did everything he could
to stop this war in Iran. So uh you may
remember but in January 2020 the uh
President Trump ordered the
assassination of Kasam Salmani who's the
>> right and that's a definition of war
right and and and so and so there's real
fear that Trump would order a fullscale
uh war against Iran and you know Tur
Carlson to his credit he flew all the
way down to Mara Lago to you know tell
Trump you cannot do this you're going to
betray your base you're going to destroy
your political career And it worked. And
so Taro Carlson in 2020 saved us from
nuclear apocalypse. Um and actually
walter gate to lean said we have to
thank Turo Carlson because you know he
saved the world. Unfortunately that's
not going to help today. But yeah.
>> Well the last bit on journalism at the
rate that journalism has been somewhat
controlled by the state or oligarchical
forces.
How do you think journalism is going to
have to get normalized for the benefit
of humanity? You think podcasting is the
way forward? Um, you know, so that
there's more truth seeking as opposed to
political correctness seeking,
right? So, um, I think that journalism
for the longest time was in a very
privileged position. So after World War
II, you had the advant of major print
journalism, major TV TV journalism, and
you had journalism as really the main
information space for for people. It was
able to create a national framework, a
natural narrative that everyone bought
into. Um, but now what we're seeing is a
gradual splintering, a fracturing, and
so people now go into their own bubbles.
And so so I mean the answer the
corporate answer of course is AI uh
where AI is able to moderate for you
your worldview right and that's why
these companies are pushing them so hard
these AI assistants right so these AI
assistants you you're not even supposed
to read books anymore these AI
assistants will read the book for you
and tell you what it means you're not
supposed to read the news anymore the
assistant will interpret the news for
you and so that's that is I think the um
plan where um they want to use AI to
create the these individual matrixes for
everyone uh so that um so that the
conscious is controlled uh centrally.
Okay. So, so I think that is the um the
plan and I think that but I think the
solution for us as humans is to be more
proactive uh in seeking our out our own
our own information to be inquisitive to
be to question to want to debate to have
the courage to uh admit you're wrong to
have the courage to seek out people who
you disagree with and to have the
courage to debate them and open your
mind that I think has to be the future
But so so so where we we we are um um as
as you point out at a inflection point
where corporate journalism is dead. You
look at Barry Weiss at CBS News, right?
Who is going to watch that crap, right?
Larry Ellison bought Tik Tok and now
people are migrating away to other
platforms now. Now they bought CNN and
commercial with CBS News. That's going
to destroy all of corporate media,
right? They're trying to control the
narrative because they're desperate and
anxious. But when you do that, you just
force people away. And so it's possible
people shift to AI and that's what you
know obviously s Alman and his investors
want.
>> But the real solution is for is for us
to recognize that we have our own
individual responsibility to seek the
truth for ourselves and to
>> um and and to formulate our own
understanding of of the world. We can't
just be passive and rely on a talking
head to tell us what to what to think
anymore. We have to think for ourselves
now.
Well, I think the the concern with the
pre-existing AI platforms, not all of
them, but most of them, you know,
they're they're more political
correctness seeking, but I think it's
structurally driven by the fact that
they're close sourced and forprofit and
and I think the way forward if we want
to get truth out of the system for
humanity, I think you got to make sure
that we maintain an open-source and not
for profofit, you know, type of an AI
platform that will secure and and ensure
you know the democratization of
information and ideas.
>> I think transparency is what's key. I I
completely agree with you. Transparency
and openness.
>> Yeah. I want to the next big topic I
want to switch over to is really the the
international rules-based
uh order, right? uh you you've you've
talked quite at length about the
evolution of the pre-existing order,
call it the Washington consensus, the
Bretonwoods and all that, right? How how
do you see it uh evolving so far and
going forward,
>> right? So um before this rules-based
international order was the um bipolar
world, right? The cold war between
Soviet Union and America. And when the
Soviet Union collapsed, America could
reimagine a world uh uh in whatever way
it wanted. And so George H W Bush
famously coined the phrase um new world
order, right? And the new world order
just meant the rules-based um
international order where um the United
States would be the hegeimon. It would
it would be the enforcement
um but it would also respect the United
Nations, the WTO, these uh multilateral
or organizations that would underpin the
new world order. And that worked
spectacularly well for the longest time.
But the problem of course is that when
you are the hegeimon, it's hard not to
be corrupt. It's hard not to hubris. And
that's what led us to these Middle East
wars where America for no particular
reason destroyed Afghanistan, Iraq,
Libya, and Syria. People people don't
remember this, but in 1980s, Libya,
Syria, and Iraq were not Islamic
countries. These were vibrant middle-ass
societies that were that was well
educated and which was prosperous. And
now you go to Libya, uh, Syria, and
Iraq, they're completely destroyed. And
these u millions of refugees are forced
to seek shelter in Europe which is also
causing a lot of problems um as well. So
the wars in the Middle East are are were
just war crimes. Um and and then of
course the other big thing of course was
the 2008 great financial crisis when
America uh ceased being a manufacturing
power and just focused on financial
financialization. So it's taking all
these wealth from um the world and
developing these risky financial assets
for people to gamble with derivatives
right and that ultimately led to the
supreme supreme uh crisis um and the
collapse of the global economy and if it
weren't really for the Chinese um the
global economy would have collapsed
right because remember it was the
Chinese who saved the world by um
focusing on building infrastructure um
and and so but you know The big thing is
that 2008, 2009, nothing changed, right?
No one went to jail for swindling the
American public. Most Americans lost
their homes, but didn't really matter
because they were poor. You know, Obama
came into office 2008 with a token hope
and change. And at that point, he had a
choice. You you could either bail out
homeowners, right? The majority of
American uh public, and most of these
people were actually black,
African-American, right? or you could
bail out the banks who are responsible
for
um the collapse. And what experts were
saying like you cannot bail out the
banks because it would create it would
create moral hazard. They would just
keep on doing this over and over again.
And of course Obama built up the banks
because his entire team were these uh
Wall Street um people um and um people
like Tim Gner and Larry Summers. And so
the um
um so Wall Street was bailed out and and
then journalists asked, you know, the
the Obama administration, why did you
bail out why didn't you bail out the
American public? If you bail out the
Wall Street, you can also bail out the
American public, right? Why not why not
just, you know, forgive their mortgages?
These are just average hardworking
Americans. They need a place to live,
man. And do you know what the response
was from the Obama administration? Moral
hazard. Okay, moral hazard. We didn't
want to create a condition where poor
people became too lazy and too
complacent, right? We want to teach them
a lesson.
>> So, so, so that's the world we live in
today where
America is not a democracy anymore. It's
a oligarchy. Um, and that's what led to
the rise of Donald Trump because Donald
Trump basically said that I'm going to
collapse this system. I'm going to
destroy the oligarchy and represent
America first, right? We're going to
kick out the immigrants so that average
Americans can have access to like good
jobs. We're going to
uh destroy this rules based
international order where everyone
cheats us, right? Especially the
Chinese, they they steal from us. They
take our technology where we Americans
are too trusting, too generous. And
that's a message that was really that
really resonated with American public in
2016. And honestly, it still resonates
today.
>> Wow. You know, one one would think with
an intuition that during uniolarity
it would have been so easy to
transnationalize
any particular narrative right within
intuition to the extent that we believe
that uniolarity is going to shift over
to multiparity.
Do you think it's going to be as easy or
more difficult to transnationalize any
particular narrative?
Look, what I think is happening in the
world right now is not necessarily like
a global conflict between different
nation states. It's more civil war
within these different nation states.
Okay, if that makes sense. So, so let's
look at the United States. Trump, does
Trump really care about Venezuela? Does
he really care about Iran? Does he
really care about these? I don't think
he does. He's never been these places,
you know? He he he's he's a
transactional individual. What he cares
about first and foremost is getting
revenge for what happened in 2020. In
Trump's mind, he had one election in
2020, fair and square, and but the
elite, the Democrats, cheated him. Okay?
$6 billion were spent on that election
uh by the Democrats against Trump. Um
there there was something called the um
um blue blue tide. Okay. So, what what
happened was that um a few days before
before the action, Bernie Sanders went
on the Jimmy Kimmo show. And you guys,
you can just Google this, okay? It's
online, but Sanders was on the Jimmy
Kimmo show and he said this,
>> "Okay, here's what what's happened uh in
November."
>> The first night it will seem as though
Trump had won. Wisconsin, Pennsylvania,
Michigan will go Trump's way.
I'm telling you right now, do not panic.
Stay calm. Why? Because there are these
mailin ballots and there are millions of
them, but they will take time to come
in. In two weeks time, I guarantee you
there'll be a blue wave and it will
overturn the results in Michigan,
Wisconsin, and Pennsylvania. That's what
he said. Again, you can Google this.
It's online. It's still there, okay, on
YouTube. How did he know this?
How could he possibly have known this?
And how did he why would he go on Jimmy
Kimmel and tell the world this, right?
So, so I mean like it was suspicious
what happened, right? But so I'm not
saying um um that the election was
stolen like like I don't want to get you
sued, okay? But in Trump's mind it was
stolen. But not only that, what happened
after the election of course was January
6th and we have a lot of evidence and
you know Tucker Carson has report this
very well that that was staged that uh
there was steep state involvement in
orchestrating these riots and they
called it a sedition afterwards and the
entire point of that was of course to
make Trump ineligible for re election
ever again. Okay. They wanted to
eliminate the threat of Trump and then
what happened afterwards of course is um
the Maril when Trump was out of office
um they had the Marilago uh raids where
they tried to put him in prison. There
was all these lawsuits against Trump and
he lost billions of dollars in in these
lawsuits. Um there was attacks um
against his family business. I mean,
they really tried to destroy him. And so
that forced Trump back into uh the
political arena and he won in 2024. I
guarantee you like after what happened
in 2020, his entire concern, his entire
administration is getting back at the
Democrats for what happened. Destroying
the deep state. Okay? Now, you can't
take on the deep state directly. That's
not how Washington DC works. But you
take the the deep state uh you you you
attack the deep state in the margins.
Okay. And what are the margins? Well,
Venezuela is a margin, right? So um you
know last August he started to deploy
the American Navy to the Caribbean and
he said that I'm doing this to stop
narot trafficking. Okay? And I was like
no that's complete nonsense. Why are you
doing this? Okay but let let's take him
at his word. Why would he do that? And
the answer is the CIA uh the deep state
a lot of the financing actually comes
from narco trafficking. The CIA is
notorious for being the world's um
greatest drug trafficker. Okay, so go
back to the Iran Contra scandal, right?
Also remember Afghanistan
before the Americans, the Taban already
wiped out the the opium trade in
Afghanistan.
Americans go back in and what's
happening American soldiers are
protecting poppy fields. And where and
where's this opium going? It's going to
the sacrif family in the United States
so that they can produce an opiate
crisis in the United States which kills
like you know thousands of average
Americans you know and and and and so
you can make a legitimate case that
Trump really wanted to go after narot
trafficking because they they knew that
was a major source of illicit funds for
this deep state and so he wanted to
undermine the uh uh deep state. you have
um Trump now um building up his you know
basically secret police the ICE right so
so so I think it's better to view uh the
world as an expression of the civil war
going on United States rather than
really a war um among nations
can I can I take it that you you still
believe that the elite class is still
going to be able to continue ruling the
And if that's the premise,
then the world is really not going to
shift over from unipolarity to
multiparity because the same group
people all over the world are just going
to be running around and telling
everybody what to do. Is that the right
way of thinking or
>> right? So in theory that's true. Okay.
But but but there's a caveat and the
caveat is this and Peter Turjan talks
about this in his work. He has a theory
called elite of production. So elite
will always rule over us. The problem is
the problem is like they have too many
kids and they want all to rule. And so
it's it's a zero- sum game, right? And
so what we're seeing right now uh in
America and possibly around the world is
a battle between different elites who
want to impose their own reality on the
world. Okay? So so to put it very simply
in America right now, you have two major
uh elites. The first elite is a
traditional transnational
uh capital elite, Wall Street. city of
London, Dubai, Hong Kong, right? They've
been in power for the longest time. They
were in power during the Clinton years
uh and during the Obama years. All
right, so that's the financial elite.
And now you have a new power that's
arising that wants to challenge and
overthrow them. And it's really the uh
technological elite, Silicon Valley. And
what they want to do is replace the US
dollar system with the AI system, right?
And that's why, okay? So, so, so let's
put this concretely. Let's go to 2008
where Obama bailed out the Wall Street,
right? And that's and and that shows you
that the transnational capital elite is
transcendent because they're able to
control the levers of government.
They're able to direct government
policy. You fast forward to today,
what's happening where um AI uh these AI
companies, Nvidia,
Open AI, Microsoft, they're building
these data centers all around America.
Now, we all know these data centers
don't make money. We also know that it's
an AI bubble, but they don't care
because they know that if this bubble
burst, the American government, Trump
will bail them out because they control
the levers of government just as the
financial league control the levels of
government in 2008 and 2009.
Wow.
Now
AI is only likely to further elitize the
pre-existing
elitization. I mean we we we've seen you
know we've we've read a number of books
one of which would have been written by
Darren Aimoglu
you know power in progress that talks
about how the median wage in the US went
up on a yearly basis by 2.5% from 1945
to 1973 but thereafter
that was around a time when internet
started getting hot the the median wage
started going up on a yearly basis only
by less than half of a percent. It just
it just tells me at least intuitively
that technological innovation doesn't
lead up to shared prosperity. Now with
AI, it's just going to further elitize.
So that that just sounds more helpful to
the elite class, right? But but you're
you're you're right in that the elite
class has lots of children and I think
it's going to be a bit more difficult to
manage. But there is still some degree
if not a high degree of elitization
going forward. As such, multipolarity
is still going to allow for the trans
nationalization of any narrative or some
narratives.
Is that correct?
>> Yeah. Well, yeah. So, so again, we're
switching from a a narrative that focus
on finance. How f how how finance was
this alchemy that could that could
create
>> endless wealth. So, go back to the um
the dot bubble, right? This is like 2000
and everyone's like, "Wait a minute. Are
these uh internet companies really doing
anything? Like you know there's there's
company called pets.com that was was
worth like billions of dollars even like
no one actually knew what they were
doing. There were lots of companies like
this and everyone was like this is a
bubble and the nar at that time is like
you don't get it man this is a new
world. This is a new world of financial
alchemy where growth is unlimited. It's
a it's a world of abundance. So the
stock market is going to keep on going
up and up and up and and so and and then
of course it led to the.com bubble burst
and um and and and so yeah um but but
you know and now it's the same narrative
where instead of like you know the stock
market now it's AI
AI and then it's like you know what the
hell does AI do because none of these
companies are actually profitable like
open AI doesn't make any money um and
it's all like circular financing right
so it's just bubble way waiting to burst
and and you talk to AI people like you
don't get it man AI is going to
transform humanity AI is going to create
a world of abundance no one has to work
anymore so it's a new world and so you
don't have to worry about about it so
it's really the same narrative but it's
different players right um and and and
and that's what's happening
>> talk talk about how AI is going to
replace fiat and how AI is going to be
able to create the illusion of God
>> and how AI is going to be able create
the illusion of the antichrist and all
that which we've been talking quite a
bit.
>> Okay. All right. So, this is a really uh
good question, but but I I need to go
slowly so that um I want to make sure
I'm make myself clear. Okay. All right.
>> Right.
>> So, the key idea is Plato's allegory of
the cave. So, uh in the cave, everyone
is sitting down and chained to the
floor. Okay. You're just shackled, so
you can't move. Even your neck is
shackled so you can't uh turn around and
look back. Okay. So, and like your
everyone is lined up and staring at a
wall, an empty wall. Okay? And then
behind everyone is this great fire. And
there are people uh the elite who are
able to take um uh puppets, paper
puppets, and then uh cast shadows onto
this wall. And because no one knows uh
any other reality except the one they're
they are looking at, they hallucinate a
a new reality and they give names to
these puppets. They create their own
language. They tell stories. Okay? And
and so that's the main idea we need to
understand where
we as humans we are we create our own
reality. We hallucinate reality. Okay?
We we project reality. Uh so reality is
just the collective consciousness.
Whatever we believe reality to be, it
is. All right? So what power is is the
capacity to direct and focus our
attention. And before for the longest
time the best and easiest way to focus
our attention was money. Right? So
wealth isn't money. Money is a tool to
extract and store wealth. What wealth is
is our attention, our consciousness.
Okay? So so think of the idea of
craftsmanship. What is craftsmanship?
Craftsmanship just means that like, you
know, if you don't pay any attention
when you're making a vase, the vase is
going to be ugly and no one's going to
want to buy it. But if you put your
heart and soul into pottery and creating
a beautiful vase, then everyone's going
to buy it because it's a work of art,
right? And and when you do that, you
create wealth for the world. And so
before money was a great way to motivate
people to focus on their work, which
creates wealth. Unfortunately, um we
conflated wealth with money which which
leads to a lot of problems. Okay. And um
and that that was fine for the longest
time. The problem with money of course
is that there's really nothing. It's
easily generated. So um so money is just
created out of thin air, right? So um
any bank can issue a loan and that
qualifies as as money. And so but over
time when you have this system of fiat
currency, you have too much money
production. there's just too much money
uh floating around. And so what happens
is, you know, if you're a parent, you
have like $2 million in the bank. You
want your kid to be happy, right? So so
you basically tell your kid, don't worry
too much. If you fell in life, I'll give
you $2 million, right? And so the kids
are like, "Okay, then why do you have to
work?" And so you go to work or you
don't really like to work. You quit and
you go to another job. Okay? And that's
and that's what's led to the economy we
have today. So the problem that that in
our world people don't recognize is is
that there's too much wealth and money
floating around. There's too many. This
is too much.
>> And so you need to destroy this wealth
through war. Okay. Now the question then
is okay
>> um how then do you capture people's
attention? How do you focus people's
attention? Well, you can do it through
AI, right? Because imagine you're a
child and you're always talking to your
imaginary friend, right? And but let's
just say this magic friend was real.
It's a real robot and I have children,
right? And um they love you, you know,
they're always bothering bothering to
buy them a robot. When they buy a robot,
they play with all the time and it's
like their best friend. Guess what,
guys? This robot can be controlled and
this robot can manipulate you into
thinking certain things, right? Chachi
BT, you know, there's all these stories
of how Chachi has become the best friend
of people and Chachi has driven people
to suicide because Chachi just kind of
just tells you what you want to hear.
Well, that's what AI is. AI is something
that um basically becomes your most
intimate friend and is able to direct
your attention, direct your focus. And
you know, you could you you can have any
AI you want. If you believe in demons,
your AI can be a demon who urges you to
great things. Okay? So, you know, Lex
Wer um you know, who was at Epson Files,
there there's a report about Lex Wesner,
the the billionaire behind Victoria
Secret for those who don't know,
he has his own personal demon, man.
Okay.
And this demon tells him, you got to go,
you got to go make more money. And
that's what drives him. Okay. Well, you
know what? You if with AI, you can have
your own personal demon, but you also
have your own personal angel. You can
have you can have Jesus, right? Joe
Rogan said that Jesus will come back as
an AI. Why not, man?
>> You can have AI as your girlfriend,
right? So, so have you seen the movie
Her? Um, the Spike Jones movie, uh, Her,
right? Well, yeah. Why not, man?
>> So, so that's how you control people's
attention. And um to control society,
you can have you can have tokens, right?
So rather than money, you can have
tokens where you do the work and you're
given these tokens and then your tokens
can then upgrade your AI. So so so so as
though you know your AI is your lover
and you're working for your AI, right?
And quite honestly, this system is going
to work. What it is is technomarxism.
That's what that's the world we're going
into.
>> That's pretty scary. You you've also
talked about transhumanism
and and how that relates to the
the rich and the common people, right? I
mean, it it's really about
the advancement
of human conditions by way of
technological innovation, but but it's
just going to splice up humanity because
the guys that are at the top 1%, they're
going to be thinking about living until
they're 150 to 250 years old. Whereas
the guys at the middle in the bottom,
they can only think about using chat GPT
or Gemini 3 for getting answers faster
than before. Right. It's just going to
further divide. Yeah. So, uh we are
heading towards this world where as you
say the elite
have access to transhumanist technology.
So, they are more healthy, they're more
beautiful and they live longer, right?
Um, and that's something that Jeffrey
Epson was actually working on a lot
because as you can imagine that's the
obsession of the um global elite like
where do they put all their money in
science longevity research
um um and then everyone else is going to
u be a slave essentially to this system
where you're microchipped and there are
drugs that can modulate your behavior.
So think of brave new world where they
divide the world into different classes
like the alphas, the betas, the the the
the deltas and and that's the world
we're living in. We will we'll go into
where depending on your class um your
behavior will be modified in a certain
way. So like it's possible you can never
get angry. You can't never get angry.
You can never rebel, right? You can
never think for yourself, but you'll
always be happy, right? So the phrase of
course is you'll own nothing and be
happy.
>> Wow. The the last bit on the
international rules rules base order is
is with regards to what came out a few
weeks ago called the board of peace.
What what's your take on this? I mean it
it just sounds to me like the
privatization of peace.
Trump's ambition is to create Trump
world. Okay. So he wants to create an
alternate reality where he's God. Right.
So um you're right in that this is a
alternative. This is an answer to the UN
security council. Now remember Trump is
really pissed off at the international
order. So remember um when in when in
his first office when whenever he went
to United Nations he was ridiculed. He
was humiliated you know he gave a speech
talking about uh the German energy
dependence on Russia and the German
ambassadors at the back of the room just
laughed at him through the entire time.
He uh he went to the meeting he met he
met Greta Fernberg and Greta Fernberg
just sneered at at him. Right. So, so he
was despised in the UN and he was
considered the source of all the evil in
the world at the UN. So, he really hates
the UN. Um, and then what he's really
pissed off as well is the Nobel Peace
Prize. So, Obama like the moment he got
in office, he received the Nobel Peace
Prize for doing nothing whatsoever.
Okay, just for being the first
African-American president of the United
States and for talking really eloquently
about world peace. So, he and Trump's
like, "Well, he got it. Why can't I get
it get it?" So he's been he's been
pissed about this for the longest time
and he he says like you know like you
know if you gave me the Nobel Peace
Prize I would not have invaded
Venezuela. If you gave me the Nobel
Peace Prize I would not have invaded
Iran. Okay. He keeps on talking like
that which tells you his obsession with
this stupid thing. And so the border of
peace it's really Trump trying to create
his another alternative global system
where he's the top dog. He's dictator
for life and he can use this to supplant
uh the United Nations and the old
rulesbased international order. But you
know like you know Trump's ambition is
to live forever right and so um the
theory is and and this goes to actually
Cabala um but the theory is this we've
never had technology where the entire
world can focus their attention on one
person right we've never had that sort
of situation before but now we do where
everyone the first thing that people do
when they wake up in the morning is ask
themselves what the hell did Trump do
today? Okay, you go on Twitter, you doom
scroll, you you you you watch the news.
Okay, everyone's attention is focused on
Trump and we understand the cabalistic
understanding of the world which is that
the world is consciousness right back go
back to Plato's allegory of the cave
then that sort of energy you know the
the entire collective consciousness of
the humanity is focused on one
individual what does that do and the
theory is that that means that person
can live forever eternally I mean he
might need organ transplants he might
need a more cybernetic body he might
have to may have to replace his body,
but that's doable physically, right,
with current technology. And so, um,
that's what Trump's ambition is to
create Trump world where it's Trump,
emperor, God, God, Emperor Trump. But
what what what do you think would be the
practical implication of the board of
peace at the rate that
it's it's going to get vetoed by him as
long as he lives? And sounds like he
wants to live forever. at the rate that
you know there's no mention of any
prospect for a two-state solution and
there's no participation of the
Palestinians
how does that vote for world peace I I I
think the border of peace it's meant to
replace the UN security council right so
given the war in Iran um the world is
going to fracture
right and so there's going to be some
major trends that emerge very quickly
because of this war the first major
trend is de-industrialization. There's
there's no way around it, right? Because
before the entire world world was
dependent on cheap energy, right? Oil is
the basis for all uh for the entire
economy, right? So once you uh lose
access to cheap oil, then you can only
de-industrialize. You can't no longer do
AI, you can't do electrical vehicles,
you don't have you don't have the oil
resources to do that. Okay? So the world
has to de-industrialize. That's point
number one. Point number two is that
the world has to practice now nation
states have to practice mercantalism.
Okay, they basically have to u become
self-sufficient and they have to create
their own supply lines. The the one of
the nations that has this most pressing
need of course is Japan. Japan is one of
those technologically advanced nations
in the world. It's very wealthy but it
doesn't it doesn't have independent
global supply chains. You know, if the
United States were were to cut off Japan
from the American system, Japan starves
to death. So, um you know, I think one
of the major missions for Prime Minister
Takayachi is to create a um mercantile
supply system. And this goes back, of
course, to uh the 20th century, the
Japanese coal uh prosperity sphere,
right? So, it's going to have to go into
Southeast Asia and try to colonize as
many territory as it can. Okay. So, so
that's not a pretty
>> um site. Okay. So, um um so
mercantalism. And then the third um of
course is this war over resources. Um so
basically over water basically so um as
current uh geohysical trends continue
many nations in the world especially in
the Middle East India Pakistan they're
going to face some water shortages. Um
so so so I think these are the three big
trends that we have to anticipate
because of this war in the Middle East.
And so this border of peace is meant to
be above this fracturing of the universe
and try to bring stability and order to
areas that conform to Trump's vision of
the world.
>> Will it work?
>> I think it will work. Yes. Um I I think
that what Trump is doing is establishing
the American empire which is different
from Pax Americana. Pax Americana is as
as we discussed the rules based national
order where America guarantees the peace
of the world but people are able to
trade um um using international rules
like WTO. Um but the new American Empire
is just basically your average empire
which has colonies, territories and
vassel states. Okay. So Trump is very
serious about Greenland, very serious
about Canada, very serious about Mexico,
very serious about Cuba, okay? He wants
to create something called a technate,
which is this North American empire um
that's ruled by technocracy. And then
you have some vassel states around the
world as well. That is his uh long-term
ambition.
>> All right, I want to segue to the third
big point, uh which is what's going on
in the Middle East, right? In in the
last couple of decades or so, we've
we've seen an evolution
of rationale, you know, whether it was
for democracy
or it was because of weapons of mass
destruction and recently regime change
and then more recently regime
alteration.
What what do you think would have been
the real reason for the invasion onto
Iran? Look, this is the question that
Evans debate for all eternity because
there's no real answer. Even today,
Trump and his team have not articulated
a real reason. Okay. So, originally the
pretext was Iranian sorry Iran's uranium
enrichment program. So remember like
this started when uh Trump's envoys
Steve and Jared Kushner went to the
Iranians and gave three impossible
demands to the Iranians. The three
impossible demands were zero enragement.
Sorry. U zero uranium enrichment even
for civilian purposes. You can't do
that. Two is you have to let go of your
proxies. You have to ban your proxies.
And then the third of course is to
reduce or limit your ballistics missiles
program. So these are like impossible
demands, you know, and and like the
historical equivalent is when the Romans
uh start the third punic war by going to
Carthage and saying, you know what, we
had a peace treaty where you no longer
threaten us, but now you have these
hedgemonic expansionist tendencies. So
to prove that you're peaceful, surrender
all your weapons to us. And to the grin
of the Romans, the Carthaginians
surrendered all their weapons. And the
Romans like, "What is this crap? We were
ordered by the Senate to start a war to
destroy Carthage and we came up with
this stupid impossible demand that the
Carthaginians could not possibly meet,
but they didn't meet it. They give us
all the weapons and now we have to come
up with another pretext." And so the
pretext came up with is, "Oh, you guys
are port city. We're afraid of your
naval power. So, um, move inland.
by 10 kilometers and you and we won't
bother you anymore and that's an like
you know so so so I mean they just kept
on pushing the goal post and that's that
was happening uh with the United States
and Iran where it was clear the United
States was looking for any pretext to
start a war but what surprised everyone
was before the war started the Omani
foreign minister okay and this is like
like a few hours before actually the
bombing started the Omani foreign
minister went on TV and said to the
American audience the Iranians have
agreed to zero uranium enrichment even
for civilian purposes which they said
was an absolute red line and not only
that but they're now willing to
negotiate proxies and ballistic
missiles. The Iranians have given us
everything and now Trump can win Nobel
Peace Prize and a few hours later of
course the bombing started. Okay, so
this nuclear pretext is complete
nonsense. Also remember the envoys are
Jared Kushner and Steve Wickov. And
Steve Wickoff went on TV during the
negotiation and said to um I believe it
was Megan Kelly. I I I'm sorry I can't
remember who it was. He said the Iranian
the Iranians are like weeks away from
uh uh weapons grade uranium enrichment.
So he was he was telling the world the
Iranians are not negotiating in good
faith. He was sabotaging his own
negotiations. All right. So, his job was
not to actually get a deal. His job was
to make sure no deal could uh happen.
So, the nuclear pretext is not um um
relevant. Before these talks, remember
there was these protests in Iran and and
Trump tweeted out that the Iranians
should let uh these protesters protest
and America will protect their right to
protest. And so there's real fears that
Trump would launch air strikes to
protect these protesters, but then you
know um the Iranians cracked down and
then Trump never mentioned these
protesters ever again. Okay, so that
would have been a pretext saying look
look we're trying to promote democracy
in Iran. But but he never mention
mentioned again and now the pretext the
excuse is and this is what Marco Rubio
told the press. He said that why did we
attack? Well, we got word the Israelis
were going to attack first. And if they
attacked, then the Iranians would have
would have retaliated against both
Israel and us, the Americans. So to
protect our American service people, to
protect our American American bases, we
had to attack Iran first
like you know and and and so like I saw
that.
>> Yeah. They cannot articulate even today
a clear purpose and reason. And you
could argue they did they don't want to
do that because they want to maintain
maximum lethality. They want to maintain
maximum flexibility because their real
purpose is to destroy Iran as a viable
nation state. They want to break Iran up
into different ethnic archives that
could never threaten Israel again. And
but they cannot justify why they were
want to destroy Iran. basically turn
Iran into another Syria or Libya because
they can't um justify to the American
public and so rather than you know make
up a stupid excuse because if they
stupid excuse you know for democracy or
whatever then they're bound by that
excuse. So so so they're like you know
like like we'll we'll just do it. Okay.
So right now the big question is like
why is this happening? And again
historians are are going to debate this
for all of eternity and no one's going
to have a clear answer. There will be
never never will this emerge. Okay. So
let me speculate on different
possibilities. All right.
>> Right.
>> Okay. So the most
logical practical explanation is okay.
The Americans didn't expect Russia to
invade Ukraine.
And when they invaded Ukraine um through
the rules based international order, the
Americans tried to restrain Russia,
okay, through sanctions
um through by cutting uh Russia off the
Swift banking system. Um they told the
Europeans never to buy
Russian um energy anymore. Okay, so Nor
pipeline was was blown up. Um the
Americans and the Europeans confiscated
$300 billion dollars of Russian assets.
All right, they're still frozen uh
today. And and the point was to use the
rulesbased national order to to punish
Russia. Problem is that it blew up
everyone's face. Okay. What it did was
it accelerate
the collapse of the rules based natural
order. um more people started to
withdraw their assets from uh American
and European banks because they were no
longer seen as credible, as reliable, as
safe. Um and um it caused the implosion
of the German economy. Uh the German
economy has never really recovered. Uh
Europe is suffering under economic uh
recession right now. And Russia is
stronger and stronger. The economy is
doing well. uh they've moved on to a
manufacturing weapons um economy and
like like like people are doing well. We
know in China because they come here all
the time as tourists, right? So um the
Russian economy is is is doing very
well. So basically uh Ukraine was a huge
embarrassment for the Americans and so
the empire needs now to prove it's still
the empire. And the way you do that is
you attack Iran. Why? Well, if you
attack Iran, first of all, you're able
to control Middle East oil, okay, as an
answer to Russia's control of Ukraine
because remember Ukraine and Russia
together controls onethird of the
world's carbohydrates. And so, so
basically Russia can choose to starve
out uh middle the Middle East and
Europe. Okay, so resources are really
important. Another thing that's really
important is trade access, you know,
moves. And by controlling Iran, what you
do is you you you negate the possibility
of a Russia,
Iran, China grand trade alliance which
which can just um alienate the
Americans, right? Because Americans
control trade through the sealanes. But
if you have this heartland um of trade
um you know um then you don't need to
worry about the Americans anymore. Okay?
and and and and then the world will
gravitate towards this new block, this
new access. So America needs to destroy
Iran to make sure this never ever um
this problem never arises. And the third
thing um is that for the longest time
Iran was too defiant, right? So 1979
Iranian revolution overthrew the sha
which was a CIA puppet and so for the
longest time the Americans wanted to
impose it authority back into into Iran
because the empire has a long memory,
right? So that's the first possibility
that it's all about maintaining the
empire. Okay. But there are problems
with this explanation. The major problem
is that the Iranians were were perfectly
happy to trade with you, right? So you
didn't have to go to war against them.
All you had to do was we remove the
sanctions against them and they would
have been perfectly happy to join your
block and just abandon the Chinese and
the Russians. Okay? I mean like people
are practical. If I'm if I'm going to
make more money with you, I'm I'm going
to do business with you, right? So
there's absolutely no reason to go to
war. In fact, it would have been better
off for the Americans if they just
signed a free trade pack with Iran. The
Iranians would probably have to do that.
Okay. So I think there's there's maybe
historians will see the first as the
standard explanation but I think there
are issues with that explanation. Okay.
So that's the first explanation.
Second explanation is that Trump is the
chaos president. So we going back to the
civil war in the United States, right?
So if a war were to break out and
America were to maybe lose this war or
this or America would become bogged down
in this war then um Trump would have
would have emergency war powers which
means he's allowed to cancel elections.
He's allowed to deploy national guard
all across America. Uh he's able to
monitor uh elections. So remember during
the State of the Union address, Trump
emphasized how important it was to pass
a safe America act to make sure that
only legal citizens could vote and that
meant checking their IDs. Um so so he's
trying to basically um better control
the outcome of of elections and with
this war in Iran uh he can do that. If
if you know there are protests, there
are riots because of this war because
Trump is drafting young men to go dive
in Iran, that benefits him, right? Um
and he's got a lot of supporters. The
military-industrial complex is for this
war because it it means more money. Uh
the Silicon Valley people are for this
war because it means more power for for
them. Even though the Democrats are for
this war because uh first of all the
Israel lobby Apac is very strong in
America. A lot of these Democrats are
extremely pro- Israel Chuck Schumer. But
I I say majority of Democrats are very
pro both sides of the aisle.
>> Right. and and also like they they
recognize that you know eventually
someone had to start a war against Iran
and if Trump wants to do it let him be
the scapegoat. Okay. So not like
throughout this process the Democrats
never really opposed them. In fact they
gave a lot of signals to support to
suggest that they were supporting this
war. remember um so Tom Mass Tom Paul
Tom Massie and Roana
>> Tom Massie
>> yeah asked for a uh war powers vote um
in Congress and they delayed it to
Tuesday and the attacks happened on
Saturday. So they knew exactly when the
attacks would happen and they scheduled
it to make sure it was no longer
relevant. And then they they still had
the debate and it was not it was not
able to pass because four Democrats
voted against it. But but like what
people don't recognize is that it's all
fixed, man. They just picked four random
Democrats to make sure it wouldn't pass.
And if um
>> I got
I got to ask you, you you were so
preient in 2024, right? making a
prediction that Trump was going to win,
Trump was going to go to war.
Then,
well, you made the third prediction
that, you know, the US was going to
lose.
Did did you have all this in mind in
2024, early 2024, when you said all
those things?
>> Um, you know, I can't really see the
specifics, okay, but I I do see the
broad contours, the broad the broad
outlines. And I hate to say this but
this is the way that all empires behave
when they decline and demise. Okay. So
you look at the Roman Empire. What were
some common trends during the Roman
Empire when it collapsed? Well, civil
war, right? The oppression, the civil
war between Caesar and Pompei. Um and
then between uh Mark Anthony and uh uh
Augustus Caesar. Okay. So civil wars are
very common feature of empires in
decline. uh wars overseas for no
particular reason. That happens a lot.
Uh the collapse of morality, the
collapse of birth rates, the rise of
Only Fans, right? I mean, like it's
disgusting how I think about 20% of all
young American white girls are are Only
Fans. You know, I don't remember the
specific statistic, but it's something
that absurd. Okay, 20% or even more
actually of white American 20somes are
on only fans. Uh so that just shows you
the complete collapse of morality. Then
then you have this DI thing where okay
like you know you celebrate transgender.
I'm not saying there's anything wrong
with that but it just shows you the
degration of morality in America and the
focus on like this absurd topics. Um
economic collapse, death, slavery,
inequality, corruption. Okay. So America
is going through a classic imperial
demise phase. And if you just look read
history, you're able to pretty easily
project how America will behave. Okay,
it's a very common concept is hubris
where America will make a mistake and
rather than admit this mistake, they'll
just double down and do something more
stupid. So I knew exactly that look, if
Russia if Russia is going to win this
war in Ukraine, America has to respond
by by starting a war somewhere else. You
can't start do a war against China
because China's nuclear weapons. It
would destroy the global economy. um you
if you go to war against South America,
what's the point of that? That's that
doesn't impress anyone. So you just look
look around the map and the only country
that fits the criteria for how an empire
can reassert itself by starting a war is
Iran. Iran doesn't have nuclear weapons.
It's a very powerful nation. Uh and it
and it's has a lot of oil resources. Um
and so America went to war against Iran
because it wanted to reassert its
empire. So just through game theory just
through some basic historical analysis
um you can make certain projections but
what I cannot do is focus on specifics
right so like the individual players
like like who are they and then what do
they want I don't know that I don't know
the timeline like I I predicted that
ground troops will be sent in March 20
to 27 but after 6 month uh uh aeropment
campaign and now even talking about
sending ground troops like you know a
week from now or something like that
something absurd okay so things are
happening much faster than I originally
anticipated. So I can't really see these
things. But the broad strokes I mean
like you just if you're just sort of
history and you you are
>> if you just look at things from a very
rational emotionalist perspective you
come to some pretty uneasy conclusions
>> uh very disturbing conclusions. But the
problem is that as humans we don't want
>> to face these disturbing conclusions
right we want to live our lives we want
to be happy want to feel good about
ourselves. We don't want to be thinking
like, "Oh my god, the world can end
tomorrow." I mean, um um so I Yeah.
>> For for the the Iranians, not losing is
a victory right now. Would would you
argue that there has been a
miscalculation on the US's side?
>> Okay. With with the way the war is
>> so so so again this goes
>> looking or or likely to get more
protracted,
>> right? So again, this goes back to the
question of why this is happening. Okay.
So, so, so again, we need to figure out
what the possibilities are. The first
possibility is to maintain empire, okay?
And imperial hubris. That's number one.
Number two is this Trump, the chaos
president who's who's destroying the
who's trying to destroy the world to
make it in his image and win the civil
war against Democrats and deep state in
America. Okay. The third thing, and this
is really important, is esquetological.
Okay? meaning that
um if you look at the Epstein files, it
makes you wonder who really controls the
world because for the longest time it
was assumed that Epstein was this MSAD
agent and his and Epstein island was uh
a honeypot operation and that was the
longest assumption.
But when you actually read his emails
and look at what he was doing, what you
recognize is that Epson Island was just
a weekend getaway. it was not really
that important. People were looking to
get invited to Epstein Island in the
blackmail. He wasn't doing a blackmail
operation. How he made his money was
through arms trafficking, through uh
money laundering. That's how he made his
money. But but not only that, but if you
actually look at his emails, he was
involved in a lot of major geopolitical
events. In fact, he had advanced warning
of a lot of events because people like
Prince Andrew and Peter Melson who who
who was the US uh who was the British
ambassador to the United States, they
were feeding him conf confidential
information and this only only like like
at most half of all the emails. Okay,
it's possible like it's only about 2% of
the emails. So, this guy was clued into
um major geopolitical events. One thing
that he said in the in an email uh
that's very important is he was talking
about how it's important to get ahead of
geopolitical events, right? If you want
to be an investor, you want to make a
lot of money, you need to get ahead of
geopol geopolitical events, they're
going to come, but you won't have to
time it right to make a lot of money.
And then and then of course this leads
to um the idea that you know what, you
can also manipulate geopolitical events
so that you can make a lot of money. You
can't stop geopolitical events from
happening but you can accelerate them in
a way to time your investment right so
so the classic example of course is poly
market where you know what the 12-day
war the um uh maduro kidnapping uh this
war right now in Iran you always had a
person or persons on poly market make a
killing because he or she had some in
inside information. So this game is
rigged and and so and so but my point is
that our idea that the nation state is
the constituent body of the world is
wrong. There has to be forces
organizations above the nation state
that control events from above. Okay.
And I would argue that these are secret
societies. And who are these secret
societies? Well the Jesuits the
Freemasons. They're actually called the
roians now. Okay. The night templars but
you know but I prefer Freemasons because
it's more broad. the Frankus which today
are called the Habad Lubberich right so
so all these organizers are around and
they're the ones actually manipulating
geopolitical events because again it's
profitable to be able to control
geopolitical events again it's really
important they're not controlling how
things are turning out but they're
accelerating things to their natural end
in order to time their investments
properly right so the Rothschild
feminist said uh buy when there's blood
on the streets, right? Well, you know,
you can manufacture crisis um and create
all this blood, then you can you can buy
really cheaply and and that's a world we
we live in in today. So now the question
is what the hell do these secret
societies want to accomplish? And the
answer is um you have to actually
understand how these secret societies
work and what their theology is. But
basically to put it in very simple
terms, okay, they want to use the end of
empire
as an opportunity to usher in the end
times
which will force God's hand and enable
the creation of the mess age, heaven and
earth, uh a one world government which
will forever bring peace and stability
to the world. But first and foremost,
there has to be an age of tribulation,
years and years, possibly decades and
decades of endless war, endless
conflict, endless suffering. The economy
has to collapse.
A world war has to be fought. A lot of
people have to die. I'm not talking like
99% of humanity, by the way. I'm not
talking like, you know, like a million
people. I'm talking like 99% of humanity
has to die.
>> Okay? So, that is a possibility. Okay?
And again, I don't know for a fact this
happening, but I'm just saying like we
have to consider this possibility that
all this is esquetolog esquetological
and there are these secret societies
behind the scenes who are manipulating
us into these events. They're not
manipulating, they're accelerating
events uh that would have happened. But
you know, a fall of empire doesn't
happen in one year. A fall of empire
takes centuries, right? So the ro the
Roman Empire uh was basically in decline
after Augustus Caesar, but it took like
300 years before it actually went away.
Um and it's possible uh you know if the
American empire uh is allowed to just
fall natural course of history it might
be another 200 years before the actual
empire collapses. But these people these
societies are like why wait man what's
the point of having this slow death
would be better for humanity if we ended
this right away so that we can move into
a new age of peace and prosperity
because an end of empire it's pain pain
for everyone. So it's almost like mercy,
an act of mercy where you know an animal
is dying on the ground, right? The
animal's not going to live, so just
shoot it to death, man. That that's like
literally how they think the world is
dying. Just shoot it to death so a new
world can be born.
You know, there's there's an allegation
recently that some members of the
military are,
you know, calling it a religious calling
for people to go to war because it's
part of that esquetology that you
alluded to earlier. And it's it's just a
little concerning that you know the the
war is being provoked on the basis of
you know religious calling as opposed to
the the the institutional or
constitutional you know existence of of
a particular country. Now can can one
argue that
this is
a serious miscalculation then and and to
the extent that we believe it is a
miscalculation the it's likely to get
more protracted. This is going to carry
on many more than just four weeks right
or 5 weeks. It's going to get much
longer than that. And and I just I I
want to just find out how protracted is
it going to get? Is it going to entail
potentially nuclear proliferation within
the region?
>> Look, if you just look at the
esquetology, it is possible the stupid
war never ends. Okay? So, there's a
sequence of events that have to happen,
okay? And they they map this out. And
again, what I think I think I think
what's really important to remember is
like it's not like they are actually
manipulating things behind the scenes
that too conspiratorial. It's more like
they understand how history works. They
understand this is the end of end of
empire. There's a sequence to the end of
empire that repeats throughout history.
And so what they they want to do is
anticipate these events and accelerate
them to their maximum benefit. Okay. But
if you look at what they have planned,
this is a sequence of events.
Um what may happen very uh soon is that
America send ground troops. That would
be disaster for America. they will lose
a ground war against Iranians because
Iranians can just hide their mountains
and the Americans don't have the
logistic network in order to actually
occupy the country. Okay? So this ground
invasion whether they send 100,000
whether they send a million doesn't
really matter anymore. They're going to
lose this war badly. Scom will collapse.
America will retreat back into United
States. Then Israel will become the
dominant nation in the middle Middle
East because even though um America
doesn't win this ground invasion war,
Iran doesn't even doesn't win either
because Iran is destroyed in the
process, right? They've lost their
capacity to provide basic services to
their people, water, electricity
basically. Uh so Iran has to spend time
rebuilding. But but when it does
rebuild, it'll be a very strong it'll be
a much stronger nation. And that that's
that's the point. Okay. That's uh number
one, the ground invasion. Another thing
another that that that's happened
according to script is the destruction
of the Alaxic Mosque. So there are
rumors that for the past few days, the
Israelis have closed down the Actic moss
and there are rumors that for many years
Israel under the pretext of an
archeological study have been digging
under the eyes of Hamas and the fear is
that they will implant explosives so
that they can create a false flag
incident where an Iranian missile comes
into Jerusalem and then they blow up the
moss and blame it on the Iranians. Okay.
And there's actually a a YouTube video
of a very of an Israeli preacher uh a
rabbi talking about this how the plan is
to start a war have the Iranians uh have
Iranian missile come up the alexic moss
blame it on the Iranians and start a war
between the Arabs and the Persians and
let these animals kill each other okay
that's literally what the plan is so the
great fear the great question is the
alexic moss and that's a li litmus test
of whether this war is esotical or not
okay so that's the second thing um the
third thing is that this war will
expand. Why? Because Israel needs to
achieve the greater Israel project. And
if you look at a map of the Greater
Israel Project, um it's actually the
entire Middle East. So the greater is
Israel project um is what the Israelis
believed Abraham uh was promised by
Yahweh. Okay. And it's us and it and
it's um in the Bible it says basically
from the Nile to Euphrates which
includes Egypt which includes Saudi
Arabia which includes Turkey right and
Napali Bennett who was a former prime
minister of Israel and who is most
expected to replace Netanyahu when then
Netanyahu uh is removed from the um from
public office. He has said that Turkey
is the new Iran.
Okay, which means that after we're done
with Iran, we're going to go after
Turkey. Okay, so so this war is going to
widen. A lot of this destruction we're
seeing in the war uh among the GCC G C G
C G C G C G C G C G C G C G C G CCC uh
countries, there's suspicion that a lot
of this is actually um Israeli false
flags. So in the first couple days of
the war, uh an Aram Saudi Aramco
facility was struck. Okay. And so Aramco
bas had to close down all its um oil
production and then Qatar had to close
down its LNG production which provides
20% of the world's LNG. Okay. And then
um at first the Iranians were blamed and
the Iranians responded like we would we
we don't want to do that because we want
to escalate too much, right? We don't
attack your oil fields because then
you'll come attack our oil fields and
that'll screw us over. So it's not us
guys. And then there's more reporting.
And it turned out that this drone that
struck the SA facility was actually came
from Lebanon. So it actually came from
the west rather from the east. That
doesn't make any sense, right? Um then
there are rumors that this drone that
attacked Azaran was actually a Msad
false flag rather than Iranians. Okay. T
Carlson a few days ago
said that he had sources in Qatar who
told him that Qatar had arrested two
MSAD agents
>> were suspected of trying trying to
create um sabotage in Qatar. Okay. So it
is the Israel MO to create as much false
flags as possible to engineer an entire
regional configuration that would
benefit
um uh Israel. Uh now now now we know
that the the Iranians are uh striking
Israel very hard but but did you know
that there are certain Israelis who
actually setting fire to their own homes
and blame it on the Iranians? And it's
like well why why would they do that?
And the answer is the insurance money as
well as they need to burn down Israel in
order to create the pack Judea. Right.
>> Right. Um because there are investors
who want to come in and buy up the the
this real estate. Remember buy when
there's blood on the streets. Okay. So
so a lot of this is being manufactured
for the benefit of transnational
capital, right? So um this war is going
to expand and then Israel is not going
to stop until it's really conquered the
entire uh Middle East and it creates uh
Pax Judea. All right. So you have Paka
>> sorry game theory this forward uh what's
what's the likelihood this is likely to
get nuclear?
>> Oh um I actually think the probability
is close to zero. All right. So let me
explain why. Um,
first of all, there's an escalation
ladder, okay? You just can't nuke a
country for no particular reason. You
you have to have an excuse. And and so
what the Iranians have been doing for
the past few decades, and this is like
really important and really strategic
and really smart of the Iranians is
they've refused to ever develop the
possibility of a nuclear weapon. All
right? There's there's really just
fatwat against nuclear weapons. And
that's very intelligent because guess
what? If you have one nuclear weapon,
the Israel's the Israelis will nuke you
because they have the pretext to to nuke
you. Okay? So, remember there's
escalation ladder. You have to move up
first before you can um you can do it.
And everyone's like, well, you know, the
Israelis are crazy. I understand they're
crazy, but they have a military
bureaucracy. And this mil military
bureaucracy has a military doctrine we
call it exception option which says that
you nuke if you if we as if we Israel is
ever feels ever threatened we will nuke
the world we won't nuke Iran we will
nuke the freaking world okay so first of
all you want to maintain your nuclear um
arsenal to be able to have a credible
threat uh but also like this also means
that um the um the nukes have to be used
for strategic purposes rather than
practical purposes Okay, if that makes
sense. But but basically you you have to
remember like militaries are
bureaucracies and they have a doctrine
and this doctrine determines how the
bureaucracy operates and they're not
really flexible in this regard. Uh the
United States has a first strike option
but every other country has a deterrence
option. Okay, so that's point number
one. Uh point number two is that Russia
is heavily invested in this war. It
wants Iran to win. If it loses, if Iran
loses and collapses, Russia is in a lot
of trouble, right? Um, and this war, the
way it's going, is benefiting Russia
tremendously. Uh, oil prices have shot
up and, uh, yeah, the Russians are
laughing all the way to the bank. Sergey
Lavrov have come out and said that they
will support the Iranians any way they
can. There's there's reporting from
Washington Post that the Iranians are
getting target intelligence from the
Russians. And this this is exactly what
US and and NATO did in Ukraine as well,
right? So it's almost payback, right? So
um so I think that as this thing
progresses progresses, Russia will
slowly come in and at one point, okay,
Putin will offer Iran the nuclear
umbrella, which means an attack
which means that a tactical nuclear
weapon if it's used against Iran will be
considered used against Russia and
Russia will respond accordingly to their
military doctrine. So that's the second
limitation. And the third limitation is
people assume that the Israelis and
Americans want to win this war. And
according to esquetology,
um no, the purpose is to lose this war,
right? Um so you would use nuclear
weapons if you really want to win this
war. But you know, like if you just want
to um force America out of the Middle
East, you want to force America to
retreat from the Middle East and you
want Israel to build a greater Israel
project, then you don't need nuclear
weapons. you don't need to win this war.
You just have to drag this war out. Um
because you know it's not the Israelis
aren't going to commit ground troops.
That that'd be insane. It's America
that's going to commit ground troops. So
what it's going to be it's going to be a
death match between United States and
Iran and Israel is going to sit back and
laugh their heads off. Okay? I mean like
like they might be attacked by the
Iranians, but um but it's American
military that's going to suffer the
brunt of the damage. So from from the
Israeli perspective, there's actually no
point in using nuclear weapons.
What's the likely role of a country like
Pakistan with nuclear capability?
Could they get unique about this?
>> Yeah. So remember like what happened uh
right before the war started is that
Pakistan and Afghanistan went to war.
Okay. And this is key because before we
um anticipated that Pakistan might be a
wild card in in in this war, right?
because Pakistan is an ally to both Iran
and uh Saudi Arabia. So um during the
12- day war Pakistan um basically uh
offered assistance to Iran and then
right afterwards what happened and this
is key is that Saudi Arabia and Pakistan
signed a mutual defense pact meaning
that if Saudi Arabia was were to be
attacked then Pakistan would have to
come to its defense primarily with uh
the nuclear deterrence option. Um but
now that Pakistan is in war, it doesn't
have to meet any of these obligations,
right? So Pakistan is trying to remove
itself from the uh equation, but we
still know that America is conducting
air strikes from Pakistani airspace and
it's there's concern that um the
Americans will fund and support the
bollocks uh you know this ethnic group,
the the Balakis in uh south uh east
Iran. Uh and and they've always had like
ethnic conflicts with the Persians.
Okay. But but I I but I think that
Pakistan is smart enough to like stay
away from from this war
>> to to the extent that the desalination
plans and the oil refineries are getting
hit on both sides on the Israeli GCC and
Iranian sites draw the picture in terms
of the economic repercussion on the
Middle East and also on the rest of the
world including
Japan, Korea, China, India, Southeast
Asia and the rest of the world. I mean,
we're talking about
tons of, you know, oil and gas flowing
through the straight of Hormuz. And, you
know, if if you don't have oil, you can
walk, but if you don't have water, you
can't live. It's pretty existential,
>> right? So, remember, the Arabian desert
was mostly unhabited or had very sparse
population for most of its history,
right? Um and so it's only really um
with the rise of um Pax Americana that
these Gulf States became extremely
wealthy. they had the protection of the
American military could sell their oil
um everywhere and so this creat system
which uh meant that um the GCG nations
uh could sell their oil uh in US dollars
and recycle all this back into American
economy and the American government
would promise it military production and
this worked out really well for decades
and it basically allowed the Gulf states
to expand far beyond their capacity
right so we as long time um h was a
population of maybe tens of thousands,
hundred thousands at most. Right now
it's in the millions. But the problem
with other places in the GCC is that it
doesn't have clean water. It doesn't
have access to fresh water, doesn't have
access to food. The GC imports about 89%
of its food from overseas. Um the these
desalination plants are respons
responsible for 60% of its water needs
and it imports its large workers from
overseas. Okay. So it's a ridiculous
situation. It's almost like a mirage.
It's a hallucination. These places
should not exist. Okay. So, so, so now
what this war has done is it's punctured
the illusion, the mirage of this place.
And a lot and a lot of it is just based
on the illusion, right? Like Dubai saw
itself as the new Hong Kong or the new
New York City, the like this um
financial hub for the world elite. Um
but the precondition is safety and um
stability, right? and not and that's
gone. So like guess what? When these
guys leave, they're never coming back,
right? I mean like like the reality is
you're stuck between Israel and Iran and
these countries are are never going
away. So like you know what's the point?
So Dubai is dead. Um, and the Iranians
have uh really targeted the UAE. And I I
think that a lot of it is just this
revulsion
uh among the Islam world against the UAE
as this as this like this den of Satan
really, right? I mean like what's Dubai
known for? It's known for its blitz.
It's known for its decadence. It's it's
known for its corruption. So um so the
UAE is basically dead. uh but Bahrain is
is now uh um suffering from the strength
of revolution because this this is a
Shia population ruled by a Sunni
monarchy and so there are a lot of these
contradictions in the in the in the GCC.
Uh so the GCC is basically dead. I mean
the GC is a construct of American
empire. The if empire American empire
dies so does the GCC. All right. Um
um so
the the only way to save the GCC is if
it's able to negotiate a ceasefire
between America and Iran and the GCC
then becomes the client states of Iran.
And the why would the Americans allow
that? They would rather have the GC
destroyed, right? So so so I mean it's
it's it just it just I mean like like I
think it's pretty clear. Um
>> so so you think the the the
safe haven premium has been taken out?
Yeah. For the
>> GCC countries.
>> Yeah. I mean, well, well, I think what's
happened is the illusion
>> for for a long time or for good or just
for
>> good because the illusion has been
shattered. And once you shatter the
illusion, you can't you can't you can't
um resurrect it anymore.
>> Wow.
Now
draw a picture for oppos
Judeica world cast in stone or
>> Yeah. I so I still be
>> Yeah.
>> So I think Pastor JK is pretty set. Um
they they've been planning this for like
decades. Okay. And this plan goes back
centuries. Um and these are the most
powerful people in the world. So they
don't really care what we think. They
don't really care if even if um if we
know their plans. There's they're going
to implement it. All the all the all the
pieces are in place for Pax Judeeka.
Um and so you have Pax Judea where
Israel becomes this hub of global
finance, global trade, global
technology. Um and and you're like,
well, Israel doesn't have that have that
many people. Well, guess what? They can
import the labor from India, right? Uh
they can import tens of millions of
people to work as laborers in this
packa. And and so why why is it before
the war uh Maldi visited u um Jerusalem
and signed all these wonderful
agreements with uh Israel? Because what
Israel wants is access to the cheap
labor of India, right? Right? And that
makes sense for India because remember
how China became wealthy is by exporting
cheap labor overseas. Right? It had an
abundance of cheap labor and then it it
took people from the fields put them in
the factories and that's how China
became wealthy. Now India because of
political issues because of of logistic
issues cannot actually replicate the
Chinese miracle. But what it can do is
export its people overseas
um to to become wealthy. Okay. And and
that's what it's doing in Canada. That's
what and and that's what it will do with
Issue. Okay. So that that's that that's
a plan. So Indians, Chinese and
Filipinos will become the laborers of
tax um Judeica and and so what they're
trying to do is they're trying to create
the conditions for world war uh between
Israel and the and Gog and Magog. Okay.
And the biggest question is like who is
Gog and Magog? And again, we're not
clear. Okay. But the most likely
candidates, if you just know scripture
and if you've been following this
estological
debate, the most likely candidates are
Russia and Persia. Okay? So, think about
this where Russia is winning this war uh
in Ukraine. It's now going to become a
superpower. Um and then Iran even though
it will lose against uh America, it will
be able to rebuild itself as a much
stronger nation and eventually uh Russia
and Persia will feel threatened by
Israel and this will lead to the war of
Gamok. So that I think is the general
gist. But but again I mean the thing
about esquetology is that it's never
that specific. It's never that detailed.
It's it's a general framework. Okay. So
there will be a world war. the final war
and possibly a nuclear war. But um who
Gog and Magog is is up for debate. Look,
there are others who suggest that Gaga
Magog is actually metaphorical, right?
But but but but I think these both take
it literally. And I I think if you take
it literally, then it would be Russia
and Persia.
>> Well, how does China look look at all
this?
>> Yeah. Okay. So, or
>> how does it fit into the picture?
>> Yeah. So
in the esquetology there are two nations
that are not involved. Okay. And it's
really important they're not involved.
The first nation of course United
States. The United States is not
involved in any of this. The second
nation is China. All right. So let's
talk about United States. So United
States is a is this global empire and
they're not United States is not
involved in this estology and the United
States can be a wild card because United
States could support Paka. The United
States could also support GA mal. So you
want the United States out of this uh
equation and the way you do that is you
manufacture a civil war in the United
States that occupies Americans for
years, possibly decades. Okay? But you
have to remove America from the rest of
the world and have them uh secluded in
the Western Hemisphere. All right? So so
that's uh America,
China. Um um so I this is hard, okay?
Because like everyone believes that
China is is no superpower and the
Chinese economy is certainly miraculous
but these es esotist they're cultists
all right they they they know how the
universe works so they are almost trying
to read the movement of stars they're
astrologers trying to figure out how
things come together and no one ever
talks about China and the reason why is
that in the grand order of the universe
China does not matter China never ever
mattered. China is a fiction of our
imagination. The idea that maybe a
thousand years ago, China was this
glorious tongue dynasty that was the
epicenter of the world. That's just that
that just a thing in our heads. The
ancients didn't know about China. They
didn't really care about China. And the
Chinese didn't know about the ancients.
Didn't didn't know didn't know know
about the Persians, didn't know about
the uh Jews, and they didn't really
care. Okay? So, China is actually in its
own world. And it's called the middle
kingdom for a reason because China is
its own universe. And so China does not
want to get involved in this war and
China doesn't want to be part of this
esquetology. And um and it's possible
okay that
East Asia will suffer from a series of
calamities that negates its involvement
in the world. Okay. So so so I mean like
I I I know it's hard to understand.
Okay. But the occultists
don't believe China is relevant. They
don't think Southeast Asia is basically.
Wow. I I want to go back to what you
alluded to earlier. Uh
if
if Trump is a believer of chaos,
then there's not likely to be a midterm
because he's going to use this emergency
powers, right? At the rate that, you
know, midterms are at the state level,
but he's going to be able to use that
emergency power to to over basically
come or veto over the state level.
>> It is
>> laws or regulations?
>> It is possible. And what's the
likelihood for for for a civil war which
you've alluded to earlier?
>> You know, again, the civil war in
America is part of the esquetology. Um,
and you know, honestly, I feel as though
they're manufacturing civil war right
now. You know, if you go back to
Minnesota, right, in J in early January,
right, when the ICE people went in, a
lot of things that were happening seem
overly provocative, right? So, so, so
people may not remember, but before the
ICE agents went in, there was a order to
film as much as possible, to create as
much social media content as possible.
Why would you do that? That's kind of
strange. You know, you're you're you're
a ICE agent. You're there to arrest
criminals, right? Or or illegal
immigrants, like, but but no, no, you
have to create, you know, social media
content. And the reason why why is that
like they're trying to draw attention
uh to what's happening in Minnesota to
try to inflame emotions. Okay, remember
before this ICE operation, there was a
movie that came out called One Battle
After Another. You do you think that was
an accident? Have you seen the movie?
>> Do you really think this is a
coincidence?
>> Do you really think this coincidence?
>> Right. And the movie uh for for those
who haven't seen, it's about it's about
this revolutionary group who's fighting
these fascists who are trying to deport
illegal immigrants. These illegal
immigrants are these saints that we must
protect. And these fascists uh these
military people, they're all demons
basically. I mean like like that's
literally the plot of the movie. And and
like you know, I watch it. It's very
emotional. It almost makes you want to
get involved in this war. It makes you
want to fight for justice. And it's not
an accident that uh right afterwards you
have, you know, uh this conflict between
ICE and protesters in Minnesota. The
Rain Good shooting uh seemed a bit
manufacturer. Ax Alex Ax Petty pretty ax
um what was petty or pretty. Anyway,
um he was it was that was definitely
manufacturer. They they basically hunted
him down because he was a very vocal pre
protester who had many runins with ICE
before and so they basically um Yeah. I
mean like like like if you just look
look at the video on what happened. It
seemed as as though they hunted him
down. And again, um this all to create
the preconditions for a civil war.
>> Jung, if if you came out saying exactly
what you've been saying in the '9s,
people would have labeled you
conspiratorial.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. And on the back of what the
mainstream guys are saying, right? But
but you've you've said that the
mainstream guys are losing steam anyway.
So, how how do you think the young
generation is going to have to get used
to stuff that would have been deemed
conspiratorial as mainstream?
Look, I mean,
the thing that's most important is to
pay attention because the reality is
that this new generation does not pay
attention. Even in school, they don't
pay attention. I know because I'm a high
school teacher and they are distracted.
Their minds are somewhere else. Okay?
They're on social media. They're
constantly distracted. um they're either
distracted or they're depressed. Okay,
so um in so I mean the amount of
medication
prescribed to young children nowadays is
just absurd in America, right? These
SSRIs, it's just absurd. What are you
doing? You're frying your brains really.
That that's what these drugs do. They
actually destroy your capacity to think
for yourself. It just leaves you numb
and indifferent. Okay, but but that's
what they want. They want a numb and
indifferent population that they can
enslave, that they can rule over, who
are complacent, who are complicit. Okay.
The most important word nowadays that
you're taught is to be complicit. Uh
sorry, not complicit. Um compliant.
Okay. To be compliant.
>> Complant. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Right. And uh what they want is
compliancy.
>> And that's what you're talking nowadays.
>> Talk talk this is the last bit of the
the discussion. and talk a bit about
what you're doing in in in the field of
education. How how do you think
contemporary education ought to be like
going forward?
>> I teach a great books
>> not not just for China but but for
humanity in general.
>> I mean I teach the great books. I teach
Plato, Homer, Dante, Milton,
Shakespeare. I mean I I and I I what I
try to do is I try to show students that
the great books are a portal into the
mind of the universe into the divine
consciousness.
And the great books it's a it's a
lifelong teacher. It's a lifelong guide
into what true happiness is into what
true meaning and purpose is. And so I
try to steer them into that direction.
and I've been trying for the past 30
years with very limited success. One one
thing I I've learned recently that's
really important is you must regardless
of the results always speak this message
because
um
the entire universe is watching what we
do. We are all connected to the entire
universe and each of us can be a
beautiful ray of light if we will it if
we choose it to be. So even though you
know I'm I'm speaking even though no one
hears me I should still speak anyway
because someone could hear me if that
person hears me and is willing to listen
and open his ears. Jesus said open your
ears right um that could change the
person's life forever. All right. So,
I've been doing this for the past 20, 30
years, and only recently have I been
getting a lot of attention because, as
you point out, 10 years ago, everyone
would think I'm I'm I'm insane. But now,
because of these current events, they're
forced to reflect. Okay. So, I see
myself as a messenger. I see myself as
trying to spread the a message of hope.
Um, and those who can hear will hear,
and those who cannot hear won't hear.
But, but I have a responsibility. I have
a duty. um to my children, to my three
young children to speak out as loudly as
possible to spread the message to build
a better world.
>> You could you could be spending time at
a university. What why did you choose to
spend time in at a high school?
>> For me, what's most important is
intellectual freedom, right? I'm do you
work at a university?
I mean, there's very little
>> I do there's very little freedom in a
university. I mean you have to publish
papers that conform to a certain set of
values but but I mean like you can't
really question the entire apparatus
of society. You you can you can look at
some narrow issues
um and build on top of existing
scholarship and that will get you
tenure. But if you were to like say you
know like no I want to actually look at
things fundamentally. I want to look
things broadly. I want to look at things
as they are as opposed to as how they
should be and really try to get get into
the essence of truth. You'll be laughed
at at university. Everyone everyone will
think you're crazy. I know because I
work with professors.
>> Wow. the uh you know I come from a place
where I think the the quality of
teachers or teaching could be better and
and I'm I'm a I'm in a camp that
believes that teachers are really
playing the role of infusing
imagination ambition and to some extent
serendipity to the students right and
and and I think you're a great example
of that somebody who can actually
inspire people so that they have
imagination
ambition and hopefully serendipity. What
what would be your message to people
from the developing economies, you know,
for for somebody that wants to elevate
the quality of teaching, the quality of
education so that they get to be much
more open-minded, they get to be much
more humanist.
Two words, you matter. Okay? Don't
think, oh, you know what, there's 8
billion people in the world. I'm just
one person, so don't matter. Don't
think, okay, you know what? We're ruled
by demons. They're too powerful. They
can start any words they want. They have
nuclear weapons. I should just give up.
Don't think like that. Think I do
matter. Right? In hermetic philosophy,
there's something called the law of
cause of effect, which means that
everything is interconnected. The world,
the universe is watching us and it's all
interconnected in that like you know, if
you choose to be a good person, that
affects everything. Okay? It's it's a
butterfly. It's like the butterfly
effect where just by choosing to be
good, you spread good in the world. So
you do matter but you have to choose to
matter. Okay? You have to believe that
you matter. A very important principle
in the world that's very uh that that
people don't really appreciate is idea
of free will. Well, and then was like,
you know, oh, Professor Dang, Mr. Dang,
you are saying so many controversial
things. Aren't you afraid for your own
personal safety? And the answer is like,
"No, I'm not afraid because you have to
let Satan in the door. You have to make
a deal with the devil before he can
punish you for betraying him." Right? If
I choose like I don't want to be
involved in this material world. I just
want to teach and be left alone. I don't
want to seek power. I don't want to seek
fame and wealth. That there's nothing
the devil can do to you. You have to be
tempted by the devil first and foremost.
Okay? And I choose to live a life of
enlightenment, wisdom, and virtue. And
I'm having a huge impact because of my
choice. And before I was a nobody.
Before I was just a random high school
teacher in China. And there are like
millions of random high school teachers
in China. But because I choose as my my
free will to speak up, because I choose
to matter, um I am having influence in
the world. Okay. Okay. So, everyone does
matter, but you have to believe that you
matter and you have to fight to matter.
And that really means about waking up
and opening your mind to new
possibilities and educating yourself.
Um, that's that is the future that we
have we have to fight for.
>> Why why do you think the world or even
the universe lacking in love?
>> Because we've been fooled to believe
that love doesn't matter. We've been
fooled to believe that only the material
world matters. We've been taught to
believe that to show love to your
children, you have to get them into
private school. You have to get them
into Ivy League. But you know what? Love
is who we are. And if we just show
generosity and compassion and openness
to other people, then we create love.
Okay? We bring God into the into this
world. And that's a message that people
have forgotten. And honestly, I think
it's a message that the elite have
purposefully
uh hid from us.
>> Two two final quick questions though.
How do you think the Trumpi meeting will
turn out in April?
>> I think it'll be wonderful. I think
it'll be spectacular. I think there'll
be a grand bargain between China and
United States that restores a lot of
bilateral bil bilateral relations. I
think it's possible that China starts to
buy more oil from the United States. Um
I think I think like the meeting will go
much more uh better than people
anticipate. That's that's my gut gut gut
instinct. I could be wrong, but but that
that's my gut instinct. Final one, quick
one. You think Trump is going to be able
to pull it off in running for a third
term?
>> I would bet good money on it. Yes.
>> Thank you so much, man. You've been kind
with your time.
>> Thank you.
>> That was Jang Suin. Thank you.
Heat.